there are large racial disparities when
it comes to who is getting the covet
vaccine
in baltimore maryland african americans
make up more than 62 percent of the
population
but only about 32 percent of the
vaccinations there have been
administered to the black community
our national correspondent jerica duncan
takes a look at the barriers to vaccine
equality
in some of baltimore's most vulnerable
neighborhoods
thank you for wearing your mask for
keeping your distance
that's the voice of kobe little he
drives this truck through baltimore
[Music]
educating vulnerable communities on the
corona virus
and now the vaccine rollout little
is president of the baltimore city naacp
he says policy makers and health care
providers are overlooking the needs of
the black community
i'll give you an example in this phase
rollout one phase
is for seniors 75 and above in baltimore
city
the life expectancy of an
african-american man does not reach 75.
this is not unique to baltimore there
are several factors contributing to
vaccine inequity says mark martin
he is maryland's deputy director for the
office of minority health
and health disparities i hear you say
hesitancy and access
are big issues when it comes to
vaccinating
the most vulnerable populations of
people but we spoke to a 62 year old
woman
from baltimore i haven't been notified
to um
take my shot yet but i'm waiting who
said she registered at three different
locations
two months ago to get this vaccine and
she hasn't received it yet
we continue to work through the
registration process again one of the
things that we try to do
is just stand up these vaccination sites
as quickly as possible
in addition to expanding vaccination
sites martin says the state is turning
to churches for help
we are not prepared to fight a virus
that
is killing persons churches like new
psalmist baptist where pastor walter
thomas says
it's not just about saving souls it's
about saving lives
he wants to turn his church into a
vaccination site
do you think it's more of a problem of
vaccine hesitancy
or not having the access at this point i
think it's both
i think it's an information problem
and i think it's a logistics problem
people don't understand
you don't have cvs stores and giants
and markets all over
large sections of certain
african-american communities
they don't exist so how does that
translate into not being able to get a
vaccine
it all slows down because the economic
infrastructure to
build those persons up doesn't exist so
half of them don't have cars
martin says the health department's next
step is bringing mobile vaccine units
into the heart of the communities
that need them the most how soon do you
think that could realistically happen
as soon as possible again what does that
mean
two weeks three weeks two months
hopefully within the next couple of
months for sure
the city's health department as you
heard could not give us
a timeline as they say it really depends
on when those doses
come in now as for access the state
health department just
recently as of last week opened up a
call center making it easier for people
to register to get that vaccine by phone
instead of online tony his report shows
there are decades of disadvantage and
you're not going to fix that in just a
number of days jerica thank you very
much but we have to try of course